I turn the alphabet into an acronym this
was many years ago when I was first
starting out in stand-up comedy I had
this idea because my mom was texting me
I was when my mom was first texting me
still figuring it out still trying to
figure out all the acronyms Etc and I
thought it'd be really funny to kind of
mess with her and suggest that there are
different acronyms out there and got
into my head what
little bit was an acronym and when it
comes to Comedy sometimes it can be
helpful to have a constraint to have a
certain idea not necessarily know the
full idea of the punch line but to say
okay really funny concept of the
alphabet is an acronym what could it
possibly stand for and that's where a
writing session helps because you have
this as initial idea maybe you think of
it while you're walking down the street
or in the shower or whatever but later
when you sit down to write now you have
an opportunity to build from something
so that's what I did because I sat down
actually this was in a still in
University and I was in a very boring
class so I just spent the entire class
saying okay what could the acronym stand
for if you had all 26 letters back to
back what could it be and for me I came
up with a story but I'd love to hear
what you can come up with with the
acronym as an alphabet my story was a
baby cat died earlier from giant
hairballs it jumped knowingly Landing
millimeters near an oasis peering
quietly Raven saw the algae Vermin with
x-rays and yell exams
now some of you are thinking like okay
really I don't think a cat's technically
a Vermin and would they say sounds I
don't know but still that's not the
point